I have no arms and no legs,...
...but I'm very thankful that I have my little chicken drumstick here.
People freak out when they see me for the first time.
It's so cool! I was at a waterslide all by myself.
Everyone obviously at the bottom of the slide is looking up,...
...waiting for other people to come down and here I come, and they're freaking out.
They're like,...
...you know, like this.
And I was so tempted to look at myself and go, "What happened?"
There were times when I sort of looked at my life and think,...
..."Well, I can't do this," and "I can't do that".
And you keep on concentrating on the things that you wish you had...
...or the things that you wish you didn't have.
And you sort of forget what you do have.
And there's no point, I believe, in my life, where I wish I had arms and legs,...
...I wish I had arms and legs, I wish I had arms and legs,...
...because wishing won't help.
But what I've seen in life are just a couple of key principles.
And the first thing that I've seen is to be thankful.
I tell you, when I was 8 years old, I sort of summed up my life...
...and thought I'm never gonna get married,...
...you know, I'm not gonna have a job,...
...I'm not gonna have a life of purpose.
What kind of a husband am I gonna be if I can't even hold my wife's hand?
It's a lie to think that you're not good enough.
It's a lie to think that you're not worth anything.